i want to play this for you this is this
is a a totally bizarre story out of
florida and i think florida gets a bad
rap sometimes
it it's not the crazy state in my
opinion california is the crazy state
oregon is the crazy state even vermont
is the crazy state um
i i think florida is unfairly labeled
that way
although this we're about to play a
local news report for you
every aspect of this is
weird so let's watch what the local news
has to say about uh about this incident
here let's watch
finally you understand what's going on
that's a school principle
no put your hands down
hitting a six-year-old with a wooden
paddle in front of her mother
the hatred of which she hit my daughter
i mean it was a hatred that really i've
never hit my daughter like she hit her i
never hit her that's her that's the
mother speaking she's speaking spanish
i'm reading the subtitles to you
we know the name of the woman with the
paddle through a report from the henry
county sheriff's office
it says the principal of central
elementary melissa carter and cecilia
self a clerk are the two women in the
video
we tried to reach them through the
school district but were unsuccessful
the child's mother recorded this video
why didn't she stop the beating
mother says if i had done it with my own
hand it would have been bad for me
i don't know mom told deputies the
school called tuesday april 13th
saying her daughter damaged the computer
the fee
50 in the report mom says the school
also mentioned
paddling with her and a deputy present
in the report the mother says she didn't
understand the process correctly
later that day she went to the school to
pay the fee and they took her into the
principal's office
she already had her there then the
principal started to scream
mother says behaving and taking care of
the stuff
you don't keep messing up things mom
looks around
no cameras nerves set in bueno
there are no cameras what are we doing
here in this place my daughter and i
alone
so she did what she thought was her only
option
how do i prove if there wasn't a camera
she hid her cell phone in her purse
and press record okay
stop it right here pause right here
we're gonna we're gonna cut out of the
video right here but
but okay so you get what happened here
um
the girl got in trouble six years old
damaged a computer
they sent a note saying that she's going
to be paddled for it
and the mother shows up to be present to
be witness
to be a witness at the paddling but she
didn't she didn't want her daughter to
be paddled
and rather than step in and prevent it
and say hey don't hit my kid she watches
it
and films it and this is the reason
she's giving
in the subtitles she says
oh my gosh she says i sacrificed my
daughter
so all the parents can realize what's
happening in this school
so that's why she didn't step in because
she was offering her child up
as a sacrifice to raise awareness
about the corporal punishment issue at
this school
as i said every part of this story is
bizarre i i don't understand exactly
what's happening here well with the with
the mother i think i do understand
what's happening
um she as unfortunately parents so often
do these days
they see their kids as a chance to go
viral
and get attention and file a lawsuit and
so if i were to speculate because we can
only speculate about about
somebody's motives um and so in this
case
when another adult is gonna hit your kid
and tells you they're gonna
yeah she said she was confused by the
process it's written down there
like we're gonna paddle your kid with a
wooden board that's what we're going to
do
what are you confused about here what do
you mean what do you mean
what do you mean with a wood paddle with
a warden board do you mean like
metaphorically
what do you mean by that i think they
were actually pretty up front it seems
about what they were going to do
ma'am we're going to be uh hitting your
kid with this board right here
and you're going to stand there and
watch
now if this were me
and uh and i didn't want my child to be
hit by another adult which i wouldn't
and we'll get to that in a second
i'm going to physically intervene like
walk over and say you're not going to do
that
you think that's what any parent would
do if they actually wanted to stop it
she didn't so we can again only
speculate my speculation
is that she saw an opportunity to file a
lawsuit just she says that uh
she she sacrificed her daughter so all
the parents
um can realize what's happening in this
in this school this is like a
some kind of perverse christ scenario
sacrificing
child is sacrificed um but i think she
sacrificed her daughter
you know if i were to again just
theorize i would say she sacrificed her
daughter
uh to get that big bag of cash from the
lawsuit
so that's the mother part of it now
we've got to think about the school
i mean first of all it seems like this
is something that they just do
i didn't know that this existed anywhere
in the country still
i'm i'm actually kind of shocked it does
um and they do this and now there's
controversy like
did do you not know that that's how
people are going to react have you have
you
been in our society for any length of
time
have you seen the way things go you
think you can
paddle kids with a board at school
and it's it and people aren't gonna be
upset about that
now the thing is you know the idea of
corporal punishment
um i think a corporate punishment can
have a place
in the home i think that's that's
parents have to make their own
parenting decisions and uh you know
children respond differently to
different kinds of punishments
i don't think that there's a
cookie-cutter one-size-fits-all approach
when it comes to discipline and
punishing
and some some methods work for some kids
some methods don't i mean
there are some kids that you can put
them in time out in a corner
and and and that's really going to get
the message through and
you don't really need to do anything
else there are other kids who they don't
care about that and
you might as well not be doing anything
they you put them in a corner it makes
no difference
so kids are different kids have
different personalities
in the home you can make your
decision about how you want to handle
your kid
at school though no i mean that's what
i'll say i don't
like i'm old-fashioned on a great many
things
and i understand that back in the day i
mean my own parents will tell me stories
um about this kind of thing when they
went to school
and this is what happened when kids got
out of hand unruly
you take out the ruler take out the the
paddle
and you handle it that way um
but now my my general policy here is
um if you're you know as
as another adult you're not going to lay
a hand on my kid
man as simple as that and really what it
comes down to is
this is a a power and an authority
and a tool that i don't
trust the school to wield
literally and figuratively i'm not going
to trust the school with that
i think some parents can be trusted with
forms of corporal punishment
um spanking and so forth with their own
kid am i gonna trust
the school system am i gonna charge a
public school teacher
to be using physical discipline on a
child no
no no no no no no no
no i'm of the opinion that the schools
are not parents
teachers are not parents shouldn't act
like
it shouldn't have the authority of a
parent
there should be a a clear dividing line
between parent and teacher
and now you are going way across that
line in my view
so that is simply again that is not an
authority that's not a power not a tool
that i would trust the school
system with government the government
school giving them you know
entrusting them with the power to hit
your child
uh no even if it's not a government
school system private school same thing
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content